good evening members and officers of the
council members of the press and public
I welcome you to this meeting of the
council if the fire alarm is activated
please vacate the offices via the stairs
either through the security doors to my
right or opposite the lift in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in hawley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise you
when it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber the Proceedings of this meeting
will be recorded and subsequently
broadcast on the internet I would advise
that if filming takes place anyone in
attendance in the public areas may have
their image captured so I urge anyone
filming proceedings to avoid filming
members of the public particularly if
there are children present does anyone
intend to film the proceedings evening
thank you very much any member of the
public who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to leave the meeting any
filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business we're
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
press and public from the meeting and
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls in the
chamber whilst this meeting is in
progress gender item number one then
apologies for absence we have apologies
from councillor Taylor Smith and
councillor Taylor are there any other
apologies
thank you very much the gender item um
to the minutes of the previous meeting
held on 13th of October 2016 I move that
the minutes of the meeting of council
held on the 13th of October 2016 be
approved and signed as a correct record
with the vice chairman second please
second it do members agree thank you
it being December it is the season of
goodwill to each and all so I'd like to
take this opportunity to remind members
that each one of us whatever our
political persuasion is here in this
place because people in our local
communities have seen something in us
and they have respected enough each of
us to trust us with their vote our
actions in this chamber should it seems
to me be above reproach we should
remember we operate in full view of the
public this should not be used to gain
advantage rather only to inform and
engage the interest of the public in the
affairs of their council I have written
to members concerning the incident which
caused me to take to my feet at our last
meeting and I sincerely hope the
incident is now closed may I please ask
all members to consider that when
speaking about our political opponents
in future we afford them the same level
of respect that has been given to them
by the residents who sent them to this
place thank you very much agenda item
original isset is number 11 the localism
ACT 2011 dispensations i call upon mr.
house the council's monitoring officer
thank you very much chairman my am low
compression body the association of
secretaries and solicitors recent
received counsels advice regarding the
declarations of interest and in
particular regarding members allowances
and the advice of counsel is that the
payment of allowances is a disclosable
pecuniary interest under the localism
ACT and therefore i'm taking it as read
that members will want to declare those
interest or block which accept but of
course that would mean that no member
could vote on the matter and the way to
cure that it's actually to agree a
dispensation for members
based again on the localism ACT so I'm
recommending the council agree a
dispensation to allow members to speak
and vote on allowances but also I'm
widening that to include matters which
used to be in the previous standards
regime as general dispensation but are
no longer in that regime to make sure
that we cover all potential general and
confidence interests or general interest
and therefore gives us a general
dispensation as well so i'm recommending
firstly a blanket dispensation of the
matter set out but I'm also asking that
in future I've been given delegated
authority to program dispensation 'he's
in urgent situations well it isn't
appropriate or there isn't time to make
the report to the next standards
committee so on that basis Joan Thank
You mr. house I move then that the
recommendations are set out in the
report be adopted with the vice chairman
three second seconded do members agree
thank you very much agenda item number
for them into under decorations of
interest are there any other
declamations of interest further to the
one for all members as referred to by
mr. house regarding the members
allowance item any declarations of
interest thank you Jenner item number
five petitions to the council no
petitions have been received number six
questions from the press and public no
questions have been received from
members of the press or public in
accordance with Council Procedure rule
number 13 agenda item number seven
questions from members of the council no
questions have been received from
members of the council in accordance
with Council Procedure rule 14 agenda
item number eight motions on notice no
motions on notice have been received in
accordance with council procedure Rule
three agenda item number nine the
leaders report I call upon the leader to
report on key issues that have arisen
the last meeting councillor wells please
Thank You mr. chairman as you say the
leaders report is about things that have
happened to the council since the last
meeting and probably the most obvious
and public has been the fine on our
guilty plea in court to a health and
safety prosecution you all know that the
fine walls for 250,000 pounds alongside
18,000 pounds in costs and whilst that
is hardly welcome I the either
financially or reputation alee it does
at least absolutely quantify one of
financial risks this administration has
been carrying for others past mistakes I
must make it very clear at this juncture
that this has no impact on the
compensation claims the workers who may
have suffered that will be covered
separately by our insurance company
where negotiations are ongoing I can now
repeat the statement we shoot on the day
of the judgment and that is that we as a
council have engaged fully with the
Health and Safety Executive
investigations and were prepared for the
outcome on the day we are sorry for the
impact that this has had on those
affected I would like to provide
reassurance that the council has
undertaken an extensive review of
policies and procedures to ensure that
this will not happen again we have
fundamentally changed our health and
safety processes including extensive
training and awareness campaigns for
staff as well as appointing a dedicated
Health and Safety Officer with a number
of new measures with both title policies
and procedures introduced and working
closely with the HSE we are confident
that we are do all we can to mitigate
further risk in these areas from a
budgetary perspective we are now seeing
some of the risks that we've been
carrying crystallize the bulk if not all
live animal export claims are now
settled the house prosecution costs are
now no longer term resolutions on
dreamland pleasure armor and the port
are generally awaiting events elsewhere
we are slowly but surely closing off the
expensive errors of the past one by one
so we can as a
counseling community move forward
together I am bus delighted tonight to
be able to announce ambitious and
exciting plans for the future of the
Theatre Royal in Margate working with
the Soho Theatre in London we are
planning a major refurbishment and
relaunch of the theatre the project will
also see the derelict 19 Hall d square
brought back into use as a restaurant
and boutique hotel we were very
impressed by the proposal submitted by
soho theatre following the marketing of
the theater and 19 holy square their
expertise experience and acclaim program
will bring real fresh vibrancy to the
regeneration of Margot and the cultural
offer in fact the repose will also
ensure the preservation of the
historically important Theatre Royal
which boasts I think arguably the oldest
working stage in the country the project
is in the early stages of planning and
is subject to funding and planning
consents funding agencies already
engaged and support the project and we
are working closely with the current
operator your leisure Kent limited and
would like to thank them for their
continued commitment and hard work we
additionally like to thank all others
who submitted proposals during the
recent exercise all of which we read
with interests summer theatre is a
charity and social enterprise with
ambitious plans for growth beyond its
current London base including UK and
international touring a TV and digital
arm and further venues the aim here is
for us to work with them as a partner to
transform the theater oil into a viable
business to play a leading role in the
local visitor economy and the cultural
life of our community I often accused of
blaming all ills on past administrations
so I will say at this point that we
inherited this plan from the previous
Labor administration the plan being to
offload the theatre and 19 horny square
together which I would confess privately
I thought was probably a non-starter I
was wrong and the combination appears to
have landed a bigger operator than
expected and we could all look forward
to further detail in
you course as ever these stories
continue to be reported with little
fought for accuracy in the week before
the judgment there was some
extraordinary reporting of our open and
honest budget reports on the risks we
are carrying I suppose my own particular
favorites were the BBC wheeled out sit
for representative who explained our six
billion reserves were too low and should
be 20 billion in an ideal world who then
went on to say we only had ten percent
of what we needed only an accountant I
feel could define 620's as ten percent
of anything without irony indeed the
only other person who made the same era
was also an accountant a certain mr. of
a kidney whose own accounting principles
on the election expenses seemed pretty
fictional the second was of course x
councillor driver who does his best to
continue to haunt us stating on radio
Kent we should raise council tax by at
least three percent the law you will
recall allows there's only two percent
without a local referendum the course of
which would outweigh the additional one
percent that was shown to be generated
as income even should we manage to win
that referendum for higher council tax
bill more oddity economics from the
increasingly detach Green Party it is
interesting to note that both the greens
and labour favor increased taxes the
Tories and labour increased borrowing
the lib dems seemed wedded to another
expensive national referendum on the EU
and they all say that you keep ur the
party that's out of touch I II wonder
post the very last autumn statement the
Chancellor seems to have missed the
irony of a special sort of austerity
policy which slashes council bodies by
forty percent yet managed to triple the
national debt over the same period in
passing I really should welcome the
election of Paul not all as leader of
you Kip and his belief that from
Manchester the Margay hartlepool to
Liverpool and syrup to Carrick you can
grow an electoral revolution across the
length and breadth of our land a
revolution not focused as our others on
the unrepresentative lives of lands
elite but as the true voice of up
erotic brim following review from
scrutiny the draft local plan now moves
the cabinet on December the eighth prior
to six weeks public consultation
commencing all are about 9th January
2017 scrutiny ended and cabinet will
accept a review of rejected housing
sites and understanding for the public
consultation that further evidence can
be accepted during the coming phases and
a clear indication for the consultation
that a mixed-use delegation for the
airport site does not exclude you
aviation use but it does not guarantee
aviation only use thereafter there is a
final chance to present commentary to
the inspector at the pre-submission
stage around June 2017 prior to the
planned examination in public given the
local plan technically began in 2011 we
have no room left in any timetable for
manoeuvre or delay the risks of delay
include taking over of the plan by DCLG
or indeed subject to amendment before
Parliament right now intervention by the
County Council either would mean local
councillors having little or no
influence on housing and site planning
decisions something I think we all
understand would be a dereliction of our
duty and responsibility next spring
begins to look very busy indeed the
usual budget cycles some asset disposals
due to go to auction plus the local plan
work plus the public viewing of the
business case for the possible council
merger across East Kent the decision on
moving up to the next stages and public
comment do round about April 2017 if the
case stacks up after publication earlier
in the year then I understand there
could be a county election due on the
fourth of may as well a really peaceful
few weeks through early 2017 just to
keep us all on autos I commend this
report to the council this evening and
look forward to the comment from other
group leaders Thank You mr. chair Thank
You councillor wells I call upon council
bayford to comment on or ask questions
in relation to the leaders report yeah
Thank You chairman I'd like to thank the
leader for once complying with the
Constitution and making sure that we did
get the report it would be churlish to
point out that it did arrive this
morning rather than yesterday but as it
was six minutes past midnight fell
forgive him for that one and obviously
it's not good news that we've been fine
250,000 pounds for health and safety
breaches I believe that that figure
though would be at the bottom end of the
range of possible fines and that given
the size that the penalty could have
been we might consider ourselves
fortunate to get away with that if get
away is the right term I'm not sure it
is but in any case if it's been a
wake-up call to tighten up our health
and safety procedures then perhaps it
really isn't such a bad thing and
certainly I've seen evidence of the
training that's been going on it's quite
impressive and probably well over due um
it's certainly very good news at the
Theatre Royal to get a new lease of life
it certainly had lots of full storms
over the years and I hope that this one
does come together but I think your
report indicates that there's probably a
lot of peace of the few so that got to
come together so I do wish its
successful on the subject of our
financial reserves whilst outside
comments may be the cause of some
amusement the actual level of rail
reserves is not a laughing matter it
leaves this counter in a vulnerable
position and I hope that we may be able
to build our reserves up again in the
coming years and that nothing comes
along out of the blue to hit them I
welcome your comments with regard to the
local plane particularly emphasis on the
fact that it's not too late to submit
evidence and actually influence the
final outcome I do however think that
your comment that are mixed use
designation for the mountain site
doesn't preclude aviation is a bit
disingenuous true there could be some
activity of light aircraft up there but
I doubt there are any serious airfields
that got two and a half thousand houses
like in the middle of them and you
started your report by saying that it
was about things that had happened to
the council since the last meeting now
I'm not quite sure in that context that
the election of Paul Nuttall is actually
relevant
however i would say in passing that he
must have been highly relieved that you
decided not to actually enter the rice
because it left him free to go and crap
playing the crown for himself but also
think that when you call you get the
voice of patriotic Britain I think you
may be confusing patriotism with
xenophobia finally I'd like to take this
opportunity to wish members on all sides
of the chamber officers and the
residents of fanuc a happy healthy and
peaceful Christmas Thank you Thank You
counsel bayford counting birds do issues
both sorry yes I will respond very
briefly I I trust when we come to look
at the budget setting exercise you'll
have a good look at the meeting to a
financial plan and the intention to
start the fairly long and painful job of
rebuilding reserves because it's going
to be something that's going to take a
little while but i think you will
probably find there's some bits and
pieces in there and i use the word
patriotism very consciously and very
differently because that like many other
words and many other symbols of this
nation they seem to have been taken for
political use rather than for the you
switch their intended and I certainly
like to think of ourselves as a patriot
and that's not necessarily the same as
being a xenophobe and Prancer a little
consultation with a dictionary might
help you there Thank You councillor
wells i call upon council matter face to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report Thank You chair
before I start I've been asked by cancel
Johnson to thank you for your email of
apology of what happened at the last
council meeting she asked me to say it's
been much appreciated no the matter in
hand the white finger case this could
have been resolved much earlier had the
HSE report received in 2010 been acted
upon please note the date 2010 has that
report now been phoned because I
understand it was filed
and are the conclusions in that report
the same as in the recent case that came
to court I'm could I ask please whether
trade union officers were involved
during the period under discussion
because this must have come forward at
some point I trust the reason I canceled
my face district yeah I may have been
thinking about something else but you've
lost me for a second I'm not sure that I
saw the connection to the leaders report
we've just been given it's not
appropriate it's not a fit of this point
because I'm monitoring off this cop mr.
just a word of extreme caution that we
are still in the middle of legal
proceedings I think it's inappropriate
to discuss the cases or matters
surrounding the cases at the moment
thank you and I would certainly accept
that advice but please continue
canceling my face with your response
cancel Wells referred to mine and my
understanding is there was an earlier
report so my question was whether that
had been acted upon it was by me again
we are in the middle of legal
proceedings which is still current
kaswell's referred to the end of a
prosecution case without any details I
think it's really appropriate it's just
details on the middle of legal
proceedings
well I'll move on then I'll bow to your
obviously on legal knowledge which is
not mine and okay the good news about
the Theatre Royal so can we be a
reassured that the relevant cabinet
member is fully or fait with the bondic
english side report 2013 which was the
less latest in the long line of reports
on the theaters viability and i think
one of the major points that was made in
that report was the parking issue in the
area since this can be a barrier and
this was highlighted in the report to
the sales be various reports have
mentioned that something needs to be
looked at to make it easier for people
to come to Margate and could also ask
where this all fits in with the economic
regeneration of Margate itself and
important question about number 19 which
I gather was bought from orbit if I can
ask why it was allowed to be due to
deteriorate so long when initial repairs
were carried out but not further repairs
and you mentioned Paul Nuttall Luke its
new leader I'm sure he must be very
appealing to those that he wants to
represent seeing as how he says he wants
to privatize the National Health Service
nodding yes he would yes he has been
quoted you he has been quoted publicly
he wishes to nationalize the NHS I don't
think that's quite the best way to
announce your arrival check check the
press reports
I should privatize I do a polymer
company this is tight and I can't even
read my own typing privatised the NHS I
do apologize nationalize it opposite and
the local plan well I did dip into the
six volumes and fortunately you could be
taken piece by piece but i'd like to
remind the leader that the delay 2011
was largely due to a change in the
government which kept moving the
goalposts when it came to the National
Planning & policy framework and I would
hope that there be some kind of pracy
for the public who are being asked to
consult because if the overview and
scrutiny panel had only a week to read
it is awful lot for the public to read
and they've only been given six weeks
and I'm not looking forward to the next
version coming out on the iPad because
it can be really difficult to find the
relevant page I'm finally on the asset
disposal which you refer to very
obliquely there I have to ask why you
are prepared to risk some viable
businesses by selling them off and have
to ask if there's any scope for further
discussion on this especially since I
was reassured earlier in this year that
they were safe for disposal I feel the
most compelling need in thanet is job
creation and not killing of viable
businesses and could I just meant
ruefully at the end that December the
first which is today I'm surprised you
haven't mentioned it's the opening of
the winter shelter tonight for the
people who are sleeping rough and to my
knowledge because I had done the
training at least 250 local people have
signed up as volunteers and I think we
should commend that I did the training
last week and it was very impressive to
see so many young people middle-aged
people and people even as old as I am up
for the training and I wish the whole
scheme great success I know counselor
fairbrass was involved in setting up
that skin thank you thank you very much
couch the wealth
yes thank you is cheering I think the
ups and downs of 19 horny square have
been well rehearsed over a long period
of time and indeed the attempts that
orbit made in order to do something with
that property over quite a long period
of time in the face of opposition from
residents of Hawley square is fairly
well documented as well there were
awesome there were some major repairs
done in the last year of the label
administration and they saved it from
further damage and but it is a sits
alongside or did sit alongside a large
number of properties that we have been
attempting to try and keeping the air on
limited budgets which is why we get to
things like asset disposal as it
disposals which tend to call so much
heat and very little light which is a
nice link isn't it to gain value units
certainly I yes the day in value units
are nearing the end of their useful life
those people who work there have I think
had considerable criticism of the
council's manner and method of running
those units during the time that they
have been there and they have formed
themselves into I believe a limited
company in order to be able to take them
on if they able to actually overcome the
others who go to auction for them and
the bottom line is it's not community
organization it is a limited company
it's a limited company that's prepared
to look at profit rather than anything
else and as we are required by law to
actually get the I don't wanna get into
the best value best consideration debate
again I think which we rehearse to ad
nauseam in the past but I need to get
the best value we can from the situation
that has to be a way that we can test
that against the other people are
interested in the property as well so we
can't just sidle up to one group and say
we really like the look of you would you
like to have it and let's invent a price
which is the way it tends to come across
and yes you're quite right first
December today the winter shelters open
I was leaving that for council fair as
discussed it was in her particular
portfolio
and she's been part of the actions and
activities of put that in place and I
think it's a good moment to say a very
big thank you to her but some very hard
work in the face of some very
interesting opposition thank you thank
you I call upon councillor Grove to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report Thank You chairman
well all I can basically say is the one
that goes last says the least because
the previous speakers have covered most
points that I was interested in the
report but what I would like to say is
eddie's good news to have something of
delight like the Theatre Royal coming
back to life again though we've had a
few bad points in there but I think that
counts them all and I welcome councillor
well she's report I think it's going
okay thank you very much counter the
well three yes thank you I'm you know
without wishing to go over all grandly
there's a period in which we have had to
deal with a number of very direct
challenges from things that have gone
before us and yeah now perhaps since we
stopped some of those and quantify some
of those we can start to plan on making
some of the more positive things happen
for our Island and seeing those things
move forward into the future in the in
in due course okay thank you for thank
you very much now we come to the report
of the chairman of the overview and
scrutiny panel I call upon councillor
david saunders to present his report
okay Thank You chairman members the
report before you this evening outlines
the activities since we last met in
October of the overview and scrutiny
working panels you will also see from
the papers that the panel met on the
twenty-fifth of October when the main
agenda item was fulfilling than its
growth and development opportunities and
I'm pleased to report the panel
recommendations relating to the wording
of two paragraphs within the report were
taken on board and the text amended
accordingly in addition the panel met on
the 21st November at which the main
agenda item as you've heard this evening
was the draw
to local plan and in addition to public
speaking I was pleased to see 13 non
panel members after meeting members are
encouraged to attend the overview and
scrutiny meetings particularly when the
agenda items include an important one of
local interest and in this connection I
would this is a date for your Diaries
those were interested in this connection
i will confirm that our next meeting is
on tuesday the 13th of december and that
meeting includes an agenda item on
dreamland entitled post-implementation
review or dreamland phase 1 lessons
learned so a date for the diary and i
look forward to seeing members there in
order that everyone's aware of what's
going on or what has happened and maybe
that meeting will answer many of the
questions that we find posted in the
local press and social media members I
commend this report thank you thank you
very much cancer soldiers do any members
wish to comment on the report thank you
again counselor Saunders agenda next
agenda item is fees and charges 2017
2018 and I would advise in accordance
with council procedure rules 17.6 I will
call for a recorded vote on the motion
or any amendments and substantive
motions I call then please on counselor
talent
Thank You chair this support sets out
the proposed fees and charges to be
effective from the first of April 2017
this same report has been approved by
cabinet on the 17th of November and
considered by the overview and scrutiny
panel on the 21st of November overview
and scrutiny panel had no specific
recommendations on the report although
it is always difficult to put forward
any increase in charges these proposals
are proportionate with the scale of the
overall budget challenges and are
mindful of alternatives which would
involve cuts in services members are
asked to approve the fees and charges
set out in annex 1 in so doing it should
be noted that certain of the charges
listed do not result in income that
contribute contribute to the council's
general funds as they are ring-fenced
for specific purposes I would point out
one revision to the wording in the
schedule of charges before you on page
29 item 7b green garden waste collection
there is now a single collection charge
of 47 pounds 50 rather than a scale
charge spread throughout the year I move
the recommendations much cancer talent
is there a second to please y'all second
that Thank You councillor brim any
members wish to make comments it counts
the Gregory please cancel Gregory
Thank You German this might be
considered to be a fairly minor issue
but it has the potential to cause
problems for members of the council and
what I'm referring to is Germany's that
there are now 14 new charges relating to
the replacement of waste bins and sacks
included in the fees and charges there
obviously there are many reasons why
bins can be damaged or going missing and
this is not always the fault of the
resident as a chairman of a Residents
Association I know we've had a number of
problems in the past with large Paladine
bins being damaged by council vehicles
for example those of us who were here
when the bins and bags were originally
distributed distributed will remember
the complaints and arguments that we had
from residents that were initially
received and we were told at the last
cabinet meeting that the new policy
covering the charging for bin
replacement was being formulated however
can I ask through you chairman that this
policy when prepared be made available
for scrutiny by members and not just to
become an internal departmental policy
because I believe it's important for
members to to know the adopted policy in
case we are confronted at any time by
members of the public who believe they
are being unfairly charged thank you
thank you very much can see Gregory and
I can see that some of the fees and
charges have been amended and I can
understand that that's in line with
other local authorities which was
discussed at cabinet and you'll all be
aware I'm sure that these charges can
often be a struggle for people to afford
so I'm wondering if I could draw your
attention to the work of MP Caroline
Harris she's calling for the government
to create a fund to ensure that child
burials are free so no burden on
grieving parents and I'm sure you could
agree with me that if there were no
charges for child burials that would
lift a huge burden from grieving parents
is absolutely the right thing to do the
proposal is a central fund which could
be accessed by local authorities and if
this bill is if this bill is passed so
what I would like to ask
is can the counts all right to Theresa
May to endorse that proposal to give
grieving families some support at a time
when they need it most without incurring
any further costs to the district
council thank you I'm advised council
council on that would need to be an
amendment and I proposed it then as an
amendment please we have a second please
thank you very much any further comments
for members on the subject yeah about
this amendment I mean comments about the
amendment I it's very rare that I join
in these discussions but perhaps I could
address one issue as someone who has
actually been involved in the past time
of assisting families with burying
babies and young children for some 25
years now and it is my experience that
very few child burials actually cost the
family's money I'm not saying nun do but
generally speaking any infant born below
the age of 24 weeks there is no charge
to the parents infants between 24 weeks
and full term there is no charge to the
parents and it's usually the local
authority who picks up the bill and
we're young children are concerned it
has been my experience that usually it's
the funeral directors themselves who
negotiate with the families and i have
found most funeral directors to be very
compassionate when dealing with the
families i think the only word of
caution i would urge and i hate the
sound miserable about this is that
sometimes in times of extreme grief some
parents can't expect extraordinary
elaborate services for you
children and I think we would need to be
quite clear that what we would be asking
for would be a compassionate and
appropriate service for a child rather
than just a blanket agreement to pay for
whatever might be required I hope
members won't mind me just sharing
personal experience of 25 years in being
involved with issue it is a key issue
very important to raise it cancel the
lock ins is on the amendment yes yes
good evening everybody just like to say
that some years ago I worked in a
funeral service and the funeral judge
have worked for he just used to charge
for the disbursements I creme cemetery
fees and like not more likely the
ministry wouldn't charge it just used to
be done more or less for nothing there
are there are some people though who you
know who are have got some money in that
and they do actually want to spend out
and even so then prices were kept down
it's basically I think it's on an
individual basis by all means you know
if God people who just cannot afford it
and with a grief then you know notably
they don't I never had to pay anyway
thank you thank you yeah thank you yes i
think the proposal that's been that was
what's been proposed at the house of
commons is for the upfront costs I
appreciate and understand that there are
negotiations by the funeral directors
with the grieving parents but my
understanding is that this is not at all
what a grieving parent wants to go
through I mean the experience of the
actual MP use passing was forward cheek
spirits the death of a child herself and
the deep dark depression that she was in
the last thing she wanted was to
actually negotiate with a funeral
director us through out front costs this
is a minimal charge is nothing to do
with elaborate expenses in the upfront
charge the whole fund i think is costed
a 10 million pound for english for the
whole of the United Kingdom so you can
see the basic
fund and nothing to do with elaborate
funerals and I urge the council to
actually send this letter of support for
this particular process Thank you Thank
You councilman face I was just going to
point out that page 26 has the fees set
out which is obviously what the
recommendation is but as cancer
Campbell's just pointed out why was it
going to say is the last thing you want
to actually have to worry about is the
basic fee and whether people choose a
more elaborate for you and all that is
their choice obviously thank you very
much so we have a limb and mondays for
I'd beg your pardon council go Thank You
chairman with the greatest respect and
this is a very sensitive issue the
proposed all the amendment I don't feel
is relevant to this actual agenda item
because we're talking about an amendment
that says rushing to the Prime Minister
and in actual fact we're dealing with
that district councils fees and charges
here I would have thought there is
another avenue to bring that amendment
forward all that proposal Thank You
counsel Gregory Katz a wealthy I yeah I
understand the reason for the proposal I
also understand the comment down here
but we're not this is a matter it
relates to thanet district councils fees
and charges now I'm not clear what the
time scale is for this particular
parliamentary posle but I just wonder
whether or not if the time scale from
its it whether the answer is to actually
bring that forward as a notice of motion
that we could all approve a very next
council meeting because I'm not sure
that it does sit properly with the fees
and charges report even though the
charges overlap with the issue as such
and if council consoles do that I should
very happily second such a notice of
motion if she wanted to bring it to all
the next council meeting cancer cough
time thank you very much i will do that
i'll bring it forward as a motion to the
next council meeting thank you thank you
very much come councillor shock i noted
you were do you've requested to speak on
the original proposal
yes I know that yes please you're next
sir okay I'll just sitting and listening
as it's kristen's I try to be nice why
or can the offices explain are in this
book at 19 240 is that such a small
print is it possible is it I'm talking
blues thinking could it be good each
sector have its own page and presented
with his own spreadsheet events and
attractions in ramsgate and the economy
rounds they bring in 5.6 million pound I
went to the arrow hotel yesterday I'm
just getting to where the volunteers
worked so hard in ramsgate and their
hard-pressed events and organizers and
these new terrorists are than the pilot
objective and their cost which means
fewer events staged to become all
charged negative impact on BBC at the
moment mango town council bear the cost
we pack we prepared the heaviest load in
terms of funding and local events I've
been doing a bit of homework to that
can't get everything like that the
message is there Rams net has increased
Len charges on transfer of monies from
ran pic to TDC with no benefit to encode
could we keep to the existing levels of
5% parks and gardens that host so many
events in thanet maybe in ramsgate we'd
be better managed by town councils thank
you very much
counselor Campbell please yes I did just
one point I think obviously the the
cabinet member would like to thank
ramsgate residents for their extremely
generous contribution to the free car
parking at Leopold street and on
Saturdays it's free to everybody in
tally except obviously the residence of
ramsgate who actually pays a nine
thousand pound but the you'll be pleased
to know and I'm sure you've been told
that last night at a ramsgate Town
Council budget meeting we D we decided
to actually pay over again the overly
generous 9,000 pounds took it to to
continue the free Saturday parking at
Lee upholstery Carper thank you cata
well I trust that motion included the
five percent increase in general car
parking charges that will be most
welcome as well
members I will now ask the monitor
officer to conduct the recorded vote on
the fees and charges proposal Thank You
chairman that can begin with councillor
Ashby Catholic Bainbridge that's a
Bayford got a braidwood that's a brim
false oh yeah yeah causa buckley casa
campbell counselor Glenn Coleman cook
casa Keith Coleman cook causa Connor
casa Constantine causa crow Brown has a
Curran that's a day català della Casa
Dennis casa Dexter causa Dixon castle
Edwards counselor Eleanor Casa Evans
castle a Jeremy fairbrass castle in
fairbrass cazza Falcon casa Fenner
castle a game counselor Ian Gregory
Catholic n Gregory casa grove cutter
hatin casa Hillman castle house casa j
jones casa johnston casa Larkins català
Martin Keller matter face casts of
Parsons
councillor partington castle castle
olinda Piper chairman for council Roy
pots casa linda pots casa Rogers caseros
ecchi casa david saunders casa Maeve
Saunders has a savage cutter shankh has
a shank
[Music]
cats elastomer search thing Casa
Tomlinson counter Townend casa wells
okay thank you
[Music]
thank you very much mr. House members
the motion has been passed we have the
numbers one second
[Music]
thank you very much members there were
28 votes for no votes against and 25
abstentions
[Music]
gender item number thirteen the council
tax support scheme I call upon
councillor tanning Thank You mr.
chairman this report recommends a
revised scheme to replace the time
expired scheme that originates from 2013
this same report has been approved by
cabinet on the 17th of November and
considered by the overview and scrutiny
panel on the 21st of November overview
and scrutiny panel had no specific
recommendations on the report since 2013
the government funding identified to pay
for the scheme has been systematically
cut leaving the scheme unaffordable it
is effectively being funded by all of us
and council services will be
increasingly vulnerable if the funding
gap continues to grow the proposals in
this report goes some way to addressing
this gap frankly the proposals are not
very palatable they introduce a range of
measures that result in reductions in
the level of council tax support
provided to claimants however the
recommendations have been extensively
researched and consulted upon and have
been arrived at after careful
examination of the evidence many of them
merely bring the council tax support
scheme into line with the housing
benefit scheme a detailed equalities
impact assessment has been carried out
and is attached as a 10-bit an ex-wife
in addition there is an exceptional
hardship scheme proposed to assist those
most adversely affected by the changes
in order to be clearer about the
council's commitment to such a scheme I
proposed to amend recommendation 10 in
the report to state that TDC will
approve an exceptional hardship scheme
rather than the current wording which
says that TDC works towards an
exceptional hardship scheme with the
remainder of the recommendation
remaining unchanged although the
recommendations make the scheme less
costly
council it is still subsidized if
approved the support will still leave
than it with one of the most generous
council tax support schemes in cane it
represents a balanced approach between
assisting working age claimants and
arresting the schemes increasing funding
gap I move the recommendations
thank you very much counselor of towners
do you have a second it please then
secondly reserve the right please mr.
Thank You councillor wells the members
agree councillor constant time please
[Music]
yes I'd like to speak against this
actually and I'd like to outline the way
in which this scheme forces already poor
families into deeper poverty you'll know
I'm sure that the lowest this sim tell
this area has the lowest wages in the
southeast I've talked about this before
with workers on average per annum
earning 4047 pounds less per year it's
also got the lowest rates of labour
market participation which means people
can't find work and can't paint find
well-paid work there's lots of part-time
worker there's lots of zero hour
contracts and if you add to this the
high cost of housing is proportion of
wages you can see this is a recipe for
poverty so it's no wonder actually in
the face of that that some of our wards
are the port amongst the poorest in the
country with very high rates of child
poverty this has been explored at
council before and I'm talking about the
type of poverty that you can't easily
climb out of and I'm talking about the
type of poverty that flights lives and
blights them forever and I think there's
a lack of a local plan with a focus on
economic regeneration and I think this
is sorely missing because what we need
in this area is jobs if we're going to
really challenge this problem and that
challenge to child poverty is much
needed so I think to increase council
tax from fort five point five to ten
percent will hit those very poor
families even harder it will have a
really dire impact and the lower
threshold of savings will also have a
low of a poor impact as well and I think
it's absolutely scandalous to exclude
families and to ignore families with
with three or more children I think
that's out me absolutely outrageous and
can I further add in light of what chris
wells are said today that this policy
flies in the face of the ideal but
somehow you keep under
new leader Paul Nuttall will be a
responsive and non London centric force
for God because in this consultation
seventy-eight percent of people that
responded were against any changes so I
think it needs to be noted that the
consultation which recommended the
situation to say the same has been
ignored and I think it needs to be noted
that this will force already poor
families into greater poverty and that
isn't what we should be about thank you
very much counsel constant time
I thank you very much yes my comments
will be about the this exceptional
hardship scheme when this is developed
will connive insurances that will be
brought foot before this council to
actually evaluate and I'd also like to
yeah to actually sort of the definition
of exceptional hardship rather than just
run-of-the-mill hardship also I'd like
to bring your attention to on page 50
you've got to number 12 which is limit
the number of dependent children with
the calculation have to only 22 and
you're going to include that and but
you're not going to include number 14
which is to take child benefit and child
maintenance into account now my
understanding is that you're not going
to accept full team because that impacts
upon an increase in child poverty which
is against council policy but social but
of course there for 12 will as well so
how do you justify not including 14
which you quite rightly have not
included but are including 12 which will
also give me against council policy
increasing child poverty and fatty which
is the highest in the southeast Thank
you Thank You counsel Campbell can I
come back to you then can so tell me
please yes how can we justify penalizing
the poorest people in the community it's
difficult I have not likely brought
these proposals before council because I
am aware of the impact on claims the
government funding for this scheme was
inadequate even in 2013 since then it
has been systematically cut each year
this means that all council tax payers
are heavily subsidizing the scheme there
has been extensive consultation
throughout the sum all such schemes are
being reviewed across all kent districts
many of the proposals are merely being
introduced to bring the rules regarding
council taxable into line with housing
benefit the scheme is proposed is still
a subsidized scheme a detail could
equality's impact assessment has been
carried out an exceptional hardship
scheme is being proposed thanet scheme
will remain
one of the most generous in kept thank
you very much
thank you Joe and I'm particularly
concerned what's going to happen to
people who inevitably going to fall into
arrears because going from five point
five percent to ten percent of your
council tax obviously is four point five
percent increase and I'd like to know
what kind of policy is going to be
devised you talked about a hardship
scheme for people exceptional hardship I
think we need a greater definition at
what point people go from just being a
little bit a little bit in hardship to
exceptional hardship just playing around
with adjectives isn't really going to
help a situation so could we please have
some kind of idea of a policy with
regarding two areas are going to take
people to court in single numbers dozens
hundreds when the scheme is in fact in
operation and can we be assured that
people working in the Gateway the
Gateway plus staff will be well well
versed in how people can access the
hardship fund thank you thank you very
much I'm going to ask mr. Willis to be a
comment thank you cheering um yes on
Kelsey Campbell's questions as regards
on page 50 the item 12 and item 14 why
do one not the other number 12 regarding
the number of dependent children is not
going to generate any additional income
to the council is being proposed firstly
over and 14 isn't been proposed because
it's bringing the council tax support
scheme in line with housing benefit
scheme whereas number 14 doesn't do that
and the other point is as a result of
the consultation a greater number of
people were in agreement on number 12
than were on number 14 which is the
second reason why it wasn't put forward
the as regards counts the batter faced
question or actually it was councillor
chem was the hardships game exceptional
hardsuits game will be coming to the
council and exactly where the line is
going to be drawn as regards what
defines exceptional hardship will be in
the policy in that scheme and I can
confirm from my colleague from these
Kent services that the Gateway staff
will be cognizant with Vanessa
when the Tarkan's Thank You mr. Willis
cancer therapies Thank You chair as the
cabinet member at the time who
introduced the council tax scheme in
2011 and very proud of that I would just
like to express my regret but this is
being eroded in the manner that is being
proposed as it will actually increase
the tax burden for people on low income
and I thought that this council the
administration of this council was
claiming not to be increasing tax I was
going to ask also about the fund but
this has been answered so to speak I
will look forward to the actual details
of avi of the scheme and the manner in
which the members will be involved in in
agreeing it I know to have interest what
has just been said about consultation it
seems to me but when this consultation
but the result of his consultation came
through there was some kind of
cherry-picking as to which bit was going
to be agreed or not or recommended or
not depending on whether it suited the
this administration or not when when the
majority of people say that they want to
retain the current system it is deemed
that it is not to be to be recommended
but then further long when we have a
choice between various options then we
do consider the results of a
consultation there seems to be a bit of
double standards there Thank You counsel
fellow councillor Wells up
yeah they're not trouble is they're not
double standards they're 13 standards
because actually this is a scheme that
has to be agreed across in principle of
course all 12 dish using Kent with Kent
County Council will actually take the
majority of the council tax from from
whatever goes on and you know one of the
interesting things that we face up to is
I think is kind of time said that
there's no winners here this is a
miserable subject to discuss than a a
miserable sort of solution to try and
deal with but we have a world that's
changed a little bit since 2011 even in
terms of the amount of money that's been
taken from local councils and and and
and the catalyst can put on their
ability to raise it in terms of general
council tax rises I'm not aware that we
ever said we're not doing Council
sacralized indeed we inherited from your
good selves i'm eating term financial
plan that improve the 1.99 percent
increase without a referendum every year
into indeterminate future so it's not
like a bit all agreed on that I am
interested in the the proposal that are
the comment a little while ago that
suggests that the it's disgraceful the
poorest of our society should be judged
by a lot they've got 16,000 pounds in
the bank i'm almost tempted to ask how
many people in the room have got sixteen
thousand pairs tooling around in the
bank or whether that actually
constitutes poverty and a lot of thought
you know given the the nature of the
individuals for a lotta to or want to
take advantage of this even six thousand
pounds to the bank is a bit of a pipe
dream so you know we nobody's pretending
this is easy we're all caught between a
rock and a hard place we have to produce
agreement and consultation with our
district colleagues and with kent county
councillor as well as with with our own
consultant consultations with their own
residence dover approved the scheme last
night canter brings you to discuss this
next week and as we have shared services
with dover and canterbury the idea
really quite straightforward is we
should have fast fossil sticking line
with those two councils as well as they
are we all administer our benefits from
a joint service within that context and
a shared service has been very very
successful in terms of what it's done
in terms of simplifying processes I'm
doing things more cost-effectively so
it's not with a great pleasure we
propose this it's not with any great joy
or enjoyment it is something in a sense
that we have to do and I think the
comments about hardship scheme are
interesting it's a little bit more than
just chucking about adjectives like
we're all fairly cynical about hardship
schemes following the discretionary
scheme relating to something that became
known as the bedroom tax over recent
years and what's gone on in the courts
all around there so we are going to try
and get that right and make sure we have
something that can actually deal with
those cases where people are indeed most
in need okay so I I commend with the
derivative luck tins the council tax
support scheme to you I think in the
circumstance through done the best job
that we are able to do with the
agreement of our colleagues from across
the rest of Kent and hope that you feel
you can now support it thank you very
much councillor wells do members agree
can't quite hear that but I have a show
of hands please could I have a show of
hands please agree those in favor
ok
members of games please thank you very
much against
are there any abstentions please thank
you very much the motion is carried
thank you very much
agenda item number 14 the LED lighting
in mill lane car park I called pleased
upon councillor Suzanne brim Thank You
mr. chairman the car part lighting in
the multi-storey car parks in Margate
and brought ramsgate it's very old and
expensive to run both in terms of
electricity and also ongoing maintenance
costs we have identified a solution to
retrofit the existing lighting with LED
tubes this would reduce the annual
electric consumption by 24,000 per annum
and havin an aunt an annual estimated
maintenance saving of 10,000 pounds over
the two sites we've identified a salix
interest-free loan scheme salix is a
central based government loan scheme
which is one hundred percent interest
free we've applied for this scheme and
we've been successful in our application
the cost of the project for both car
parks combined is 70,000 pounds this is
repayable over four years ie 17,500 year
however the loan is repaid after the
loan is repaid we'll be saving in
electricity about 24,000 per annum and
6.6 thousand during the loan period the
repayments of the loan would be covered
by the annual savings on the energy
bills right there is also after the six
months and the lights are operational to
allow us to accrue save savings
additional savings are made from
maintenance the lights of a warranty of
five years and we are expected to save
ten thousand pounds per annum over both
sites there is also an environmental
impact of this project we will reduce
carbon emissions by 121 tonnes per annum
across the two sites annual kelly wit
kilowatt hour savings across the two
sides would be 240 2133 pounds a saving
of around sixty-six percent her sights I
therefore recommend the following that
the council takes advantage of the
interest-free loan offered by the
government for energy savings
and agree to update the lighting in both
mill lane car park and Leopold street
car park to LED lighting Thank You
counsel Johnson thank you I'd like to
second that proposal and Thank You
councillor brim I particularly like to
thank Robin Charles Smith for all the
work that he does not just on this but
on other projects it is in my ward the
middle lane one and I'm sure in the long
term it is the right thing to do and I
fully support it shall have a secular
thank you much council Campbell please
thank you very much yeah yeah I probably
just an oversight I just wonder why the
agenda item he's actually only mentions
mill lane car park I mean the actual
proposal is to actually upgrade both
systems simultaneously as it I mean I
mean ramsgate obviously I mentioned
before I tpain managed to TVC for their
free car parking obviously that should
be done first as we are yeah and
hopefully it's just an oversight and I'm
sure that the proposal is most welcome
and we will be supporting it as long as
it includes both car parks Thank You
counsel today please yeah I'm not quite
happy that the figures head up for the
savings that are shown here they're
talking about LED tubes being replaced
with tubes and the problem with those is
is the five year guarantee for the light
of all the tubes I've had problems with
these tubes in the past vibrating out in
the car park that could be a big issue
there may be an issue as we're looking
at the car park over a longer term of
changing for completely new bulbs over
there LEDs and light fittings because
there may be problems future proofing
the retrofitted tubes to the light
fittings that we're putting in the car
parks we may make a saving overall but
there may be a greater saving to be made
in the longer term with new LED lights
fittings thank you very much councilor
Ken Gregory please Thank You Jerry well
I'd like to thank the officers for this
report actually because it's
forward-thinking and it shows that we do
have quality officers in this council or
doing the business but a bit
disappointed about all this co2 so ever
had a place today
sanuk earth we're in actual fact I have
to inject co2 into the building's to
make the plants grow better so the ball
co2 we save presumably the lesser trees
will flourish
[Music]
children would you like to sum up please
yes it's a it's an initial saving that
we're taking and most LED lamps not
bulbs do come with really good
guarantees that you can return and I
don't know whether they all actually
come with some kind of protection aren't
the lights anyways and they sealed units
so yeah so well the LED ones that i buy
from City electrics have got 15 years
warranty on them and I've had them for
10 years and they've not gone yet and i
realize that but the thing is we can we
can replace them if they go outside of
their guarantee and this is to make
initial savings but hopefully in the
future we will be looking to making
upgrades but initially this is where we
are thank you thank you very much
everybody to members agree thank you
very much next agenda item is the
members allowances scheme 2017 2018 I
move that the recommendation has set out
in the report be adopted with the vice
chairman please second second thank you
do you remember the green thank you very
much
gender item the next one is
representation on outside bodies I call
upon the leader okay with Cheryl I think
we just have one one change paulaner to
see the quicks arrangement and at the
moment actually I'd like just put that
to one side so we can actually go into
this issue a democratic services to find
out how appropriate that now is given
that quick sparkers will change the
nature which status and the way it
operates so I have no nomination for
that this evening I'd like to talk to
them product service and perhaps come
back to the next council meeting
given up to manage agree
agenda item next then is the
constitution of committees political
balance appointments to committees
panels and boards would members please
refer to supplementary agenda number one
and I call upon the leader to make a
proposal in respect of the options
outlined in that report I think I lot
four rows option one mr. Chen thank you
proposed and seconded any member wish to
propose an alternative option remembers
the green with option one thank you very
much
nomination of members to serve on
committees group leaders can take this
opportunity now to advise of their
nomination so first of all I call upon
the leader I think she I think we've
already advised cancer Edwards to move
on to planning Thank You counsel abated
please yeah Thank You chairman um
general purposes accounts the Bainbridge
the boundary and electoral arrangements
working party councillor savage and
constitutional review working party but
somebody said they're interested in that
so it goes two counts the game is it the
appropriate time to indicate a couple of
other changes I would like to take
cancer bambridge off of overview and
scrutiny and replace her with councillor
Ashby and I would like to add to the
list of planning reserves cats raspy and
castor david saunders thank you emerg
council pay for the call upon councillor
matter face please and we haven't got
any changes I don't think Oh cute
councillor grow yes lady chairman here
changes our counselor heightened to
other view and scrutiny and myself to
planning
[Music]
x a bigger pond we now need to elect a
chairman to the planning committee I
call upon the leader to propose a
nomination Thank You mr. chairman and
lots of clothes council grove thank you
can't Slaton are there any further
nominations
next my last place as there are no other
candidates i declare that council grove
has been elected chairman of the
Planning Committee for the remainder of
2016 2017 we come next to the report on
urgent individual cabinet member
decision the purpose of this item is
only to inform council that this
individual cabinet member decision was
exempt from calling in accordance with
the overview and scrutiny procedure
rules would members please note the
report counter the Campbell I mean this
is we can debate this comic
halle where the proce the process of
calling not the content for surrogate
tearing up sorry about that yet so I can
comment on the process of calling auger
urgent call but Carl actually comment on
the actual process of what's going on
down there no okay right oh dear well
that's somewhat limits while trying to
say in fact in fact it limits it to
nothing very well said nothing counts as
a camel yes Castle Gregory well I can't
I'd like to comment on the process I
suppose and that is that I've been
intrigued by the way the capital
allocation programs kept growing down
there and you know the initial budgets
for births four and five was a million
pounds it is the process it's the way
the process has gone west gone through
the process of increasing the amount of
money that's been spin down there that's
part of the process isn't it because
obviously no one has commented on any of
the changes that have taken place down
there so these budgets chairman I'm
sorry that isn't it is right okay what
can I ask a question of the leader then
and that is that what where the actual
funding is going to be found for paying
for this process down the courts no I'm
sorry this is very tight the purpose of
this item is only to inform council that
it will simple exempt from calling in
the car to the overview scrutiny but the
comments are invited but only those that
are appropriate for those who might like
to look it up its section 15 0 para
grass PQ and art so I ask again then
please would members please note the
report thank you very much that
concludes the business for the meeting
of this council it only remains for me
to
everybody a very happy Christmas and
thank you for your interest and
involvement in the council's work to
members of the public thank you good
night
[Music]